I pray Tommy gets the help he needs his
actions are desperate and humiliating he
is a disaster spinning out of control
and he is not acting like a father but
this is nothing new
Pamela Anderson goes public blasting her
ex as her son's physical altercation
with Tommy Lee escalates to worldwide
news brandon has risked everything to
save his father he does not touch
alcohol or drugs he understands his
genetics he punched him in the nose for
all of us who he has hurt now Tommy
feels humiliated and is attempting to
destroy his own son this is the devil
this is the disease of alcoholism Tommy
Lee has now brought the LA County
Sheriff's Department into their family
turmoil filing a criminal complaint
against his 21 year old son which will
now be investigated Pam says Brandon was
acting at a self-defense and so far he
has not been charged but he is
cooperated with police he writes I
worked tirelessly organizing an
intervention and it's incredibly
upsetting that it never came to fruition
I love my father and I just want to see
him sober happy and healthy but after
reading Pam's blog post Tommy tells TMZ
that while he admits he drinks more than
the average Joe no matter how much
people want to pin me as this deviant
alcoholic abuser that isn't me when I
stood up he pushed me into a wall I
didn't want to hit my son I never have
and I never will I simply wanted Brandon
to apologize to show that he actually
felt bad but he doesn't